oh my goodness this looks like a TV like
how is this real life right now how is
this real life
hey we're camping in some place I forgot
the name of Ojai California however
because it's like oh hi all right
I am in Tahiti I am in a room all by
myself and I'm starting my solo trip I'm
very tired
excuse the tiredness yeah so for the
first night I have a very long way over
and a peak so I am staying at this is
really cute I don't want to call our
hostel because not but it's not really
will tell you there it's not an Airbnb I
don't know what to call it but anyway
I'm here and I'm spending the night I
have to wake up at 5:00 a.m. to catch my
flight to Bora Bora that's when the fun
will begin gonna be here for four days
and three nights it's gonna be intense
leaveme intense what we're gonna do what
so intense how cold it is body is
completely warm it's just my face and
ears face and ears did you bring a
beanie no why I brought two beanies I
had to be nice oh we're okay when that
works - yeah I have been alone for many
hours now so just you know being in the
airport all by myself and getting to my
flight and going a little lounge and
like eating some stuff and then but just
being alone I'm like whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
all alone me and Isaac Reed camping
because Tiff's currently or is in Bora
Bora we took the time to do our own
little nature getaway and Isaac is
having fun already he's like he's like a
dog that's been like trapped inside for
like days trying to do some father-son
type of bonding time out in nature
making burgers and hot dogs and camping
and just exploring and doing
I guess boy stuff I'm super excited only
because Isaac is super excited we had
this idea of going camping for
Thanksgiving for a while and then I
actually forgot about it and TIFF kind
of wanted you to hope for a Borah thing
so we stopped talking about it and Isaac
had it no root go hey are we gonna go
campaign for Thanksgiving I'm like oh
yeah all right yeah we'll do it so but
because because of visit enthusiasm I'm
super excited
good morning all right so it's actually
so sweet but they hooked me up with some
coffee here and look some nice yummy
mangos for the morning and some bananas
but look I wanted to show you guys love
you so pretty look at this Wow
this is what I was trying to show you
guys last night
this is so pretty maybe I could see out
in the distance but the waters right
over there all right they're about to
pick me up pretty soon so I'm gonna try
to eat this fruit and drink this coffee
as quickly as I can
[Music]
[Music]
thank you pretty easy so we recently
went camping with with Barton geo and
David and during that camping trip we
took forever to get the tent up and
because we just for completely forgot
how to put it back up but with that
recent memory I made today so much more
easy cooking is gonna be very
interesting tonight yeah it is why
should we're not using our regular pen
there's another reason be super
interesting cuz you're in the wild it's
because we forgot to bring a spatula
there's like a grocery store not that
far from here but I was thinking what if
we just picked up some sticks and
figured out a way to make everything
that we need
utilizing you know things you find
obviously we'll clean it we brought
water there's no running water here at
this campsite by the way so we brought
our own water and we've just gotta be a
little more you know survival mode you
know what I mean there's gonna be fun
hey man whoa caveman mode smarter than
you cancel yeah with a lot of modern
things like a tent all right we got the
rain tarp in I think that's what that
spore is to create a little bit of like
a
like a patio area nice can carry that
Bursa it's strong where did you get so
strong I don't know control alright can
you move everything else I starting to
rain pick out our little patio area it's
pretty sick
we got the mattress beam back in what's
up this is MTV Cribs
there's our cribs for four days this is
our bed so you will be sleeping for the
next three weeks got ourselves a little
lantern a little hole no this is this is
Lantern and then this Pow Wow
so welcome to our garden lately it's
been raining as you know you told them I
think I need a witch yeah it is getting
more cold as we speak the Sun is setting
and it's not raining but this does block
the wind a little bit and it's not even
all that windy but it's it's with the
windy enough where you can feel it on
your cheek so we decided to chill in our
patio
yeah we're gonna look for that Franco
you you get first dibs you first dibs
okay watch this
paper scissor shoot this is the life
[Music]
nature all right so I'm not fully
checked into my room yet because it will
not be ready until around 1 or 2 p.m.
and if it's currently 9 a.m. so that
means I have quite a while to kill
before I actually get my over the water
bungalow that I treated myself with so
they helped me to this restroom slash
shower area where I can change so I got
my luggage here and I'm gonna get ready
to explore oh my goodness I'm just like
soaking it all in and I literally had to
like stop myself from crying when I saw
the entire aisle and I was just like oh
my god oh my god oh my god I'm really
here I'm really here this is really
happening since I've been dying to come
here for the last decade this is
literally a dream come true and I'm just
like I'm just trying really hard to just
soak it all in and honestly you know how
I said that I was gonna take it like
just relax on the vlogging and stuff and
like storing on Instagram I'm just like
this place is way too beautiful to not
share so I'm gonna probably be using
this camera a lot more than I thought
because even just getting here I'm like
vlogging a lot more than I thought I
would be but it's just like this
experience is I'm already like
without words I'm speechless I haven't
even got my room yet
[Music]
tuna rice and salads and bread
oh my gosh I just got my bungalow this
is so cool okay so look at that you can
open this and feed the fishies look at
this guys oh my gosh this is so cool Wow
Wow oh my gosh I can't contain myself oh
my God look at this view
oh my gosh am I really here did I really
do this am I really really here I just
you look at this oh my gosh oh my god
I can't believe I'm spending the next
six days here five days six days five
days five days here I can't believe this
is real I can't believe it
this is cool look what I bought for
myself guess who's getting turned up
it's for my birthday celebration cuz you
know my birthday's tomorrow I just spent
the last how many hours okay it's 1:30
so for the last I don't know how many
hours I can't math right now I'm too
excited
I have been on the beach and I went to
go to the market like I showed you I got
the sparkling wine and then I got some
French snacks so I really like these a
lot every time we would go to Paris
I would always buy one of these but look
at this this bed is just amazing
earlier when I was just sitting on the
beach and just like being as president I
could possibly be I just kept saying all
these couples walked by and there's a
lot of people on their honeymoon I
haven't seen anyone else be alone so
everyone's here with someone else but I
didn't even like get that or anything
all I kept thinking about was oh my gosh
this is so nice I don't have to worry
about anyone else but me right now huh
because every time we travel I'm always
very like conscious of the other people
that I'm with so it's like Oh what do
you guys want to do what do you want to
eat just do whatever we want to do it
together as a group or whatever and it's
just like always a lot of back and forth
but this time it was just it's just been
so nice just being like oh I'm hungry
I'm gonna go get some lunch and then
just go by myself I don't have to ask
anyone if they're hungry too or consider
anyone else oh my gosh this is so nice
you tell I've just never had any alone
time
okay this is this has been great I'm
just so happy right now and like this is
my view right now as I'm talking look at
that like oh my goodness this looks like
a TV like how is this real life right
now how is this real life
[Music]
it is nightfall now very dark yeah what
do we got going on now we are preheating
the sting ya the brand new grill
brand new grill mm-hmm we're gonna cook
vagaries and baggers I like baggers and
you got some buns you're gonna drink
some sprite tonight yes one sprite
cramps here it's break I still haven't
seen the mean I have no idea what you're
talking about
what's right grandpa like we didn't have
the spatula so we're gonna use one of
the steaks from the tent to make that
matters worse the thing you might start
raining soon you can hear the droplets
so we got to cook these burgers fast
yeah and get inside and have a movie
night tonight
yeah now share primal movies imagine you
bring out for camping you bring a motor
which can your Wi-Fi plug in your TV and
then you have the app the TV mm-hmm very
pretty much our whole TV set
[Music]
all right
we're about to eat a burger Vaughn
biggity hmm all right dinner movie we
watched well what about Bob camping
night number one complete your call uh I
know you're like that comfortable all
right we'll get warm right now we'll
finish eating and we'll watch a movie
and then see you guys tomorrow night
tomorrow morning see you tomorrow
morning
[Music]